welcome to this video ultra made this is
brett master Emmerich on right yep yeah
he's a GM now and he has it in here he
only does not have it it doesn't have it
in his notes and I don't really remember
what is playing I've played him before
oh just once for a draw that's
surprising I thought we had more games
okay we have some some line of them
exchange Spanish and this is a funny
side line that was recommended and nihal
Marines book how Michael Maron as it is
always pronounced by us a ceremony which
always sounds weird like it like he has
some I don't know room romanian DJ or
something and no sir here's a book on
the spanish the same book author and
then he recommends this this pawn
sacrifice amir forgotten the details but
it is interesting Black has quite good
development and it's not so easy to to
get down to get coordinated with white
so I can now play can I do this rookie
aid and take stinks I can also take here
first and should Yves form
context looks forced and now this trying
to get to get the e4 pawn be 59 you for
now threatens f 2 and C 3 so I should
get one point back it's I think this is
the cell this wasn't the only way
forward now here I can take detune rook
f8 though is interesting intending rook
f3
yeah I can also go rookie a rookie eight
is interesting as well still rope do you
one do you one thing stinks okay come on
let's let's just let's just do the keep
it simple move and get the pawn back
it's definitely not bad little bit
surprised hear that he's doing it like
that but it looks dead wow it is so
idiotic that you can play everything
like instantly this just looks good for
black isn't it I mean Oh am I totally
totally off here the ship I can this
chick does not lead to that much I
thought route d3 as well
take here check can grab grab some stuff
ian king there ya hmmm I can take here
and takes you three but I would I can do
that jazz Bishop d3 chick so he cannot
play rook see Warren or something like
that I say this is the jeep on yes the
jeep on is a problem definitely
this is the problem the Jeep on at the
NGO now that's it sets unfortunately
this is really lost it's not even
something that I can fight
I have no move him absolutely normal wow
what a shame this was a very good
position before definitely can just play
book h6 or whatever yeah just one temple
but it's enough black resigns sure check
let's see no I mean I'm definitely
better I am it's just a question how to
play it rook FA dis even better jerem it
was difficult but but also this should
be good rook faaar ok this is the one
yeah I thought you can go rook to e1 but
why is this not so great push of age 54
the pledge yeah it's not so easy for a
human I mean it was quite clear that at
least it was clear to me that that black
is better here but so I wasn't this is
this is something that rook f3 now I
would need a little bit more time he's
like totally uncoordinated here in this
position rook DF seven is coming so what
I did wasn't wasn't as convincing
definitely this was this now is winning
for black of course yeah Group D 5 wins
yeah so look d5 instead of a mint is
taking all this instantly was really
weird but okay so not this one this is
just an advantage but rookie 5 is
winning the other one mmm yeah okay for
rookie five but what is the difference
the big difference
and always moving don't move the pieces
Knight f3 air rooty five wins and your
end up winning yes should be formed you
don't want to analyze this position
right come on this is this is just not
making much sense so this my mistake
this is the mistake then again be sure
before yeah check yeah I mean I don't
know what he wants here black blackish
is clearly better here it's a wide open
position with equal material where I'm
dominating with my bishop against the
really bad night so it's it's it's
useless to analyze I just screwed this
up technically check check it is really
really the problem that I'm going into
this totally lost rook endgame I need to
do something else here what exactly this
is this is enough for draw it seems but
difficult difficult for a human of
course yeah I get tons of pawns Jim comp
gives this is about a draw but okay I
don't trust this totally the big point
is that I have to play rook d5 yeah Rudy
five this is this is the the key point
okay I have to do do this another the
sound someone pointed out that there is
a way to do it without them the opponent
making moves so I should should do this
is mostly irritating when they when they
play moves okay thanks for watching